versprich mir bitte dass du deine
Guacamole nur noch so machst
für unsere Guacamole brauchen wir
Avocado Kernbestandteil Koriander rote
Zwiebel Limette Knoblauch und Tomaten
ich schnibbel alles klein
alles vorgeschnibbelt jetzt nehmen wir
unsere Avocado und halbieren sie machen
das ganz traditionell Mörser deshalb
kann ich jetzt nur eine halbe Avocado
verwenden im Mörser drin habe ich schon
mal eine Knoblauchzehe die zerstoß sich
knoblauch ist zerstoßen es folgt unsere
Avocado alter Schwede guckt euch mal an
wie cremig diese Avocadocreme allein
schon ist jetzt kommen die anderen
Sachen dazu ein bisschen Limette dran
Prise Salz und Pfeffer und das ganze
heben jetzt nur noch runter guckt euch
das einfach mal an Meister tias und in
Nachos schneiden
Nachos rausholen und zum Abtrocknen auf
Zewa dann direkt wieder in die Schüssel
hört ihr das schon und Salzen sofort
Salzen einmal durchwerfen und fertig
sind Nachos die besser sind als jegliche
Nachos hier im Laden kaufen können